can we right off the bat talk about the
elevator skin sugar golden and and
here's where I want to know is the
elevator doors close I see you running
across yeah what happened I mean they
took a little spill it was the night she
commits to everything so she really
committed to that whatever swoop so we
ended up on the ground watching the
other side they slowly start to tip over
all right all right
because everybody's like why is he
running back across there's it was a
slow clunky fall to the ground by the
way don't you also have a bet about
squats can you explain this what does it
explain the bed about squad
well there is army but yes it's boring
now so right now we're taking
suggestions from and I see the gender
you get my total tweet today okay i'ma
check it okay well I'll tell you what it
is it's someone suggested and I think
it's kind of brilliant to see who can go
the longest without saying the word no
that's pretty good
I like that yeah yeah if whoever loses
has to do a certain number of squads
would get to decide and donate to the
other person okay so it's like honor
system because we're not gonna be all
the time no no but you gotta just be for
tonight okay
yep so right now while we're
today get you right there she tried to
get you right there
how great is it though almost a year
later that you're still doing these
screenings and award season and
everybody is still talking about the
movie that this isn't a movie that is a
cultural moment I mean it's incredible
and at the end of the day I think what
we're seeing it's just so it's such a
blessing to see that this film still
resonates and it's just positive that
it's working for people you know and
that it is it was relevant last year and
it continues to be relevant there's a
universality to it and hopefully a
timelessness as well what would it mean
to get an Oscar nomination I mean
honestly I think the film itself already
won you know in my eyes you know I think
the fact that it still was talking about
it today you know the community the
culture you know kids the representation
we you know box office we did it you
know and to get I think you know a
recognition by the Academy you know on
that level it's known as the icing on a
cake you know it's just that cherry on
top it would it would uh you know
obviously you know put this movie in a
category you know very prestige category
so that would be nothing that would be
awesome yeah and the acknowledgement
from the the industry I think is always
valuable because then it is also it sets
kind of a trend that these things are
possible that you can have a popular and
power
fulfilled do you want to tell me about
Star Wars no no no okay game changes
what you lose but okay anyway anyway the
us trailer dropped and people are going
crazy I'm in it is one of those things
that will have people losing their minds
it feels like one of those movies is
gonna be I mean you know when I read the
script I read it in one sitting and I
read it with like my shoulders up like
this cuz like it was so terrifying and I
just I was so excited that he had put
this madness on paper I mean Jordan
Peele has a very interesting mind and no
I don't know what the hell's going on in
his mind but um I just feel so honored
to have been able to work with him
closely on this and kind of realize his
crazy nightmare and yeah I can't wait to
see what people will make of it I
haven't seen it myself
as you know by now I play two characters
as you do all of us and so there's a lot
of haven't seen because I was basically
playing with myself
oh so it's crazy crazy I can't wait to
see have no inside scoop whatsoever
it's gonna be a crazy night okay Screen
Actors Guild Awards are up next and
those are your peers and what does it
mean to be judged by your peers and how
important is that I mean you know it's
just incredible to hear from your peers
what they feel about your work it's it
matters so much and because you know
we're all in this doing the same thing
we all know what it takes and stuff like
that so that kind of Nod that kind of a
handshake that that is a nomination is
is extremely significant for me it's
like deep in my baby yeah we're I think
we're well we are all each other's own
worst critics you don't sound like I'm
the hardest most I know she's really
hard herself as well so to kind of get
that mutual respect and kind of like you
know admiration from your peers always
kind of goes a long way so it's alright
the next one the next Black Panther have
you even begin to think about it and
we'll Ryan definitely be back nothing
and then I want to ask you this the
chemistry between you two is amaze
YouTube YouTube yes hey but people want
it to be you see now online people want
it to be way more you understand it how
do you deal with that when everyday
everyday people are like we need them to
be more it's like a fantasy of people's
online well it's it's it's fun it's not
I mean at the end of the day you know I
think it's it's such a it's such a rare
thing to find people you have good
treatment and then two for us as actors
to find each other and get to work
together I mean it makes the work richer
right and that we actually truly enjoy
each other's company on and off screen I
mean that is a blessing I'm just
counting my blessings that I'm
surrounded by people that I have a
really good chemistry with all right
last thing I want to know which between
the two of you is the bigger fashion
person who really can't explain
inspired yeah oh my children thing which
everybody's talking about okay our
budget that you and Chadwick had the
same role basically and she had what was
fine got him yeah that whole thing
nobody really talked about it and now
everybody's like whoa wait a minute that
is true they were connected if you guys
have a moment no we uh we had a moment
years later you know we had a chance to
talk about it and it was we had a good
laugh laugh about it so we were actually
wondering when we would actually when
everybody else is gonna figure it out
and like bring it to the conversation so
we did a interview with the rap you know
as a cover store
and you know the journalist brought it
up and we in heat Chadwick said he knew
he was gonna ask it like he had a
feeling that this is gonna be the
interview with somebody brought it up
and I was like man I totally didn't see
it coming at all but we just kind of
went into the story a little bit and now
and yeah it's at that time I think I was
16
you know like 16 and um you know first
time you know coming to the soap opera
you know television series all that good
stuff and yeah I played the role so it
was uh was interesting I didn't know
Chadwick at the time so it was
interesting I found out later yeah full
circle yeah
who's a crazy full circle moment is and
he was like I got fired and then he took
my but didn't go like that didn't go
down like that
[Music]